estas experiencias impactaron el
bienestar de trabajadores físicamente
mentalmente y también económicamente
porque muchas veces el trabajo
comunitario no es pagado pagado poco o
es precario y por esas razones
trabajadores dijeron que se sintieron
fracturados y sin dinero
al fin yo digo brillante porque esos
trabajadores siguen sobreviviendo y
creando nuevas formas en común luchar
contra la opresión ellos creen espacios
para avanzar la justicia social y formar
nuevos líderes activistas entonces como
comunidad tenemos que reconocer esos
esfuerzos de mujeres y personas de
género no binario latin ex tenemos que
escucharlos no silenciar los y abrirles
más oportunidades para crear por nuevos
proyectos y nuevas maneras en cómo
organizar la comunidad ellos son muy
capaz muy brillantes y ellos nos van a
guiar a un futuro mejor